oh
[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here
airpods pro
i guess a lot of people care about these
airpods became the most popular
headphones on planet earth pretty
quickly within about two or three years
of them coming out and so smartly apples
decided to follow up with and capitalize
on that with a
professional version of them aka one
with noise cancellation and a couple
extra new features
they're pretty good so we all know
they're 250
and they're not actually replacing
airpods too as much as they're living on
the site alongside them and so they're
not just the new airpods but they're
also the best of airpods so in that
impressions video i went over each of
the new features of airpods pro and what
it does and so now that i've been using
them for about a week it's time to go
over how good each of those things
actually is so let's start with the new
design the ever so memeable new design
i think they're fine i'm not really in
love with any earbud design at the
moment so really any improvement from
airpods 2 is good to see so the stems
here are shorter which is good it
technically brings the microphone
further from your mouth but they sound
just as good for phone calls then at the
bottom of the stem you have a force
sensor instead of touch sensor now so
you're squeezing to play pause double
squeezing to move to the next track long
squeeze to turn on noise cancellation it
was annoying at first because the
shorter stem is a bit closer to the side
of your head the way they fit but then i
got used to just squeezing the sides
normally the only bummer is there's no
volume control from the buds at all
i honestly think that might be my least
favorite thing about the design i really
don't want to have to ask siri to change
the volume
every time hands-free
maybe that's just me anyway they fit
into this landscape magnetic case that
honestly is still pretty small it's
bigger than the old airpods case but it
still easily fits in a pocket and a lot
of other wireless earbuds cases have
come through the studio lately and
they're consistently typically much
bigger than the airpods case to the
point where some of them aren't even
really pocketable i can still fit the
airpods pro case in the tiny pocket i
never use inside the pocket in my jeans
so
yeah not a problem here but of course
the most important difference with
airpods pro is the silicon ear tips
instead of the hard plastic going into
your ears turns out to be a major win
for a lot of people like me who
literally can't wear regular airpods for
more than about three minutes before
they're just sliding out these actually
stay in my ears i can walk around
move more than normal work out and they
create a nice little seal and that's
already a big functional difference but
the important thing for earbuds people
is that the seal isn't uncomfortable so
typically when you put earbuds like this
into your ears you're also pushing air
into your ear too which can be
uncomfortable because it creates a bit
of pressure there but with air pods pro
the pass-through cutout that lets air
through equalizes pressure and by the
time you're wearing them it honestly
makes it easy to forget you're wearing
earbuds even for someone like me who
doesn't wear earbuds very often which is
impressive so you get them in your ear
they're comfortable they've solved the
first major problem which is staying in
your ear
the next question is
how do they sound so i have two answers
when the noise cancellation is off
they sound
just like regular airpods they're fine
when noise cancellation is on
they do sound dramatically better
airpods pro get really loud to the point
where i never need them at full volume
and most if not all the improvements in
the actual sound are as a direct result
of you having a decent seal now instead
of no seal at all before i'll refer you
to quinn from snazzy labs for an
audiophile's perspective on exactly how
airpods sound in which he describes them
as mid heavy and i completely agree but
i'll let you check out his excellent
video i'll link it below so that being
said let's talk about that noise
cancellation
this is its biggest strength so there's
three modes noise canceling
off
and transparency mode and the noise
cancellation is really impressive to me
with earbuds they do well in noisy
environments but they're at their best
with you know more consistent white
noise so something like the din of a
coffee shop or being in a car on a road
trip or even on an airplane
[Music]
you know i was just thinking about it
recently this because of the feature set
being so unique this is i think my only
pair of
noise canceling
open back
earbuds
just very strange but i do love that
they do noise cancellation now you can't
control the level of noise cancellation
but it makes everything sound better and
people who previously have only used you
know airpods or other headphones that
don't do this
will love these
then there is transparency mode which i
almost was equally impressed by so it
uses the microphones built in to pass
through audio around you and it's this
really natural sounding pass-through
with maybe a little bit of hiss or
exaggeration at the high end but in
general it sounds like you're just not
wearing anything in your ears at all
which makes it easy to forget that
you're wearing them so this is a good
mode if you're you know walking or
running next to a road or you're on a
plane waiting to hear the announcements
or just generally don't want to be
totally isolated from your environment
[Music]
oh and then there's the regular just on
mode in the middle which doesn't really
do anything crazy with noise
cancellation or transparency it just
turns the earbuds on and saves a bit of
battery this one just sounds like you're
wearing air pods with silicone tips not
amazing sound but you do have a little
bit better of a seal than you typically
would for battery overall for airpods
pro apple says four and a half hours
with noise cancelling or transparency on
five hours with noise cancelling off i
kept it on all the time i got about four
hours that's
not a full flight sometimes which is
interesting but the quick charge in the
case is at least convenient so if you do
get low you can plug in for a couple
minutes and get an hour of charge out of
that and they charge via lightning
so a couple other faqs number one do
they work with android
yes now they will again not be the best
for android they lose some of the
convenience features the auto play pause
the siri of course integration but they
do work as bluetooth earbuds can you use
third-party custom silicon tips or
replace them with foam tips that you
might like better
no as far as i know this connection
between the earbud is actually
proprietary so definitely try not to
lose them because you're stuck with what
comes in the box or you can go for the
four dollar replacement tips straight
from apple surprisingly reasonably
priced are they good for workouts
sure
i've done it they are sweatproof
technically they're ipx4 water resistant
which means you can sweat on them and
they survived for me but if i was
looking specifically for workout
headphones i would look more towards
something like the powerbeats pro which
will specifically stay in my ear better
and get beat up more and be fine but if
you want just one pair of earbuds to be
fine for everything yes these will
survive a workout better than the
previous airpods so then are airpods pro
the best wireless earbuds
yes
but no
but yes but no like there are headphones
that sound better the sony wf-1000
xm3s for example
uh
terrible name uh these do sound better
than the airpods they also have better
noise cancellation than airpods pro they
also have a longer battery life than
airpods pro they also have better
customization in their app than airpods
pro like these are technically better
headphones for sure but the airpods pro
nail so many things about everyday use
like the case size for one that's a
pretty dramatic difference and also as
dumb as these might look
there are some other designs that are
way dumber and you do get used to the
stock thing and it just ends up being
natural and of course the fast charging
is convenient and the h1 chip so that it
pairs instantly with any iphone you want
and then the rest of the apple ecosystem
and it blending in with ios 13 so well
all this stuff more than makes up for it
they're not audiophile grade headphones
they're not great dedicated workout
headphones they're not the perfect
headphones for flying but if i could
only pick one pair of earbuds to do all
this stuff with
i would pick airpods pro and a lot of
people are going to make that choice
they're imperfectly perfect imp is is
that a word that's probably not a word
but you know what that's still going to
be the title so that's been it that's my
airpods pro review they're really good
and just for fun since y'all made it
this far
if you head over to twitter i'm going to
be giving away a second pair of airpods
so you can check these out i'm going to
give away this pair of dbranded airpods
pro of course the headphones and the
case only come in white so you might as
well get some color going and customize
the case so you know exactly which one
is yours when they start showing up
everywhere details will be below but
yeah sometime in the next 24 hours look
for that tweet
that's been it thank you for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
you